earlier this week the prime minister
told us
that we have to proceed cautiously on
lifting lockdown
but nonetheless nothing in the data that
he'd seen suggested
we need to interfere with the roadmap
is there anything secretary of state
this morning that you know about
that you've seen that would require
delay
pause or modification
well it's too early to make a a final
decision on that as you said
the the prime minister and i and the
team will be looking at all of the data
over this week we've said that we'll
give people
enough time ahead of the 21st of june
date when this is penciled in
the next step to be not before the 21st
of june
and the critical thing is to
see whether the four tests that we set
have been met and
and that's in terms of the number of
cases and cases are rising slightly
the number of hospitalizations which are
much more flat
and that's because the third test the
rollout of the vaccine
which is going incredibly well and then
of course we've got to look at the
impact of
of new variants and we have seen a very
significant
impact of a new variant at the so-called
delta variant
over the last month or so yes in fact
that's
that's the big unknown here isn't it
what you call the
delta in uh varian which a lot of people
still call the
indian variant uh we don't know
yet what that's going to do what's the
latest number on that
and do you have any information on
transmissibility we heard this week from
sage that it could be
40 percent more transmissible than
the previously dominant variant so what
is the indian variant
doing to your calculations well
that figure around 40 percent more
transmissible
um it is indeed that's the latest advice
i have
that means that it is more difficult
obviously to
uh manage this virus with the
with the new delta variant but crucially
after two doses of vaccine we are
confident that you get the same
protection as you did with the old
variant
so the good news is that the vaccine
still works
if just as effectively everybody must go
and get their second jab though
because the first isn't quite as
effective on its own you need that
second
jab so ultimately it does make the
calculation more difficult for the 21st
of june but it doesn't change our
strategy
which is we all need to go and get
vaccinated and
that way we will break this link
from the number of cases through to the
number of hospitalizations
it sounds like you buy the uh the
suggestion made by chris hobson the head
of nhs providers yesterday
that the vaccine has actually broken the
link
between the virus and
serious illness and hospitalizations and
death uh
are you confident about that now well
i've said that that link is severed but
not broken it isn't completely broken
but it
we've made a massive massive difference
the majority of people going into
hospital with covid now
are unvaccinated and that
is obviously that's a challenge for them
but it's good news for all of us because
it shows that the vaccine protects you
from going into hospital
now this week we'll be opening up
vaccines
to the under 30s and so we're getting
a step closer to the point when we've
been able to offer the vaccine
to all adults in this country and then
once we've got people
everybody uh having had their second
dose
of course then you'll get this
protection that we're seeing at the
moment amongst older people
you'll get that protection throughout
the whole adult population
and and that way we can get out of this
and restore our freedoms
but you know the timing of the exactly
when we can take that step
is the big question um we are not saying
no
to the 21st of june at this point we'll
keep watching the data for another week
and critically watching that link from
the number of cases to the number of
people
who end up in hospital and it is
absolutely true that the number of
people ending up in hospital
is broadly flat at the moment whereas
the number of cases is is rising
showing that that that uh that link is
not absolute as it once was
secretary of state i want to come to the
point you raised about age in a moment
but
let's just uh close off on june the 21st
if we can if um the data demands
a judgment call because in the end it's
not the scientists who decide this it's
going to be you
and the prime minister are you prepared
for
a modification of some kind not
lifting locked down completely but
lifting most of the
restrictions for example would you
consider
lifting lockdown but uh asking people to
continue to work from home
well we consider all options and the way
that we
have set this out is as follows that
there are there are a series of things
at the moment restrictions on how you
can live your life
that we have said will be part of step
four when we can take step four which
include for instance
um the rule of six and the fact that
there's still some businesses
that are closed but then as well as that
we have
four reviews into international travel
into certification
and into social distancing for instance
and we are concluding those reviews um
and doing that work at the same time
and so of course
any of those things could be varied
social distancing for example
well we ha we haven't yet set out the
approach to social distancing
after step four and that is something
that we're working on with our
scientific advisors but as you say
guided by the science but ultimately
it'll be the uh it'll be ministers who
make these decisions
one of the things that we now know is
that you know all the ulsters people
like me we've had our double
jabs uh half the population's head is
fully jabbed
now um does that mean that we're heading
now to a situation where you're going to
want to jab
all children and
essentially make sure that
before everybody gets back to school in
september
all children have been inoculated
well i'm delighted that the regulator
having looked very carefully at the data
and with their typical rigor and
independence
has come forward and said that the
jab is safe and effective for those who
are over the age of 12.
so we're only talking about our children
over the age of 12 here
um and we're taking advice currently
from the joint committee on vaccinations
and immunizations the experts in this
on the the right approach
to putting that into practice now of
course
for the time being as of today we're
vaccinating people age 30 and over
next week we'll move to opening up
vaccinations to the
under 30s who are adults so we've got a
few weeks
yet until we come out with a plan for
exactly
um how and if we take this forward um
but
we know that the vaccine both protects
you and
helps stop you transmitting and i want
to protect education as much as
as anybody does you know i'm the father
of three
school-aged children and so making sure
that we don't have those whole bubbles
having to go home and the isolation
especially as we saw over the autumn for
instance you know that
that has big upsides for education are
you detecting anything
in the data that would give give you
cause to be concerned
about spread of virus amongst young
people and children
uh no and i think that it's very
reassuring that the
um uh that the uh that the regulator has
come forward to
say that the vaccine is uh is safe
that's in respect to the vaccine and
and young people in terms of the impact
of the virus on young people
um it is very very rare that people
that young people are affected um
very negatively there is some long
covert amongst
children um and also crucially
they can pass it on and that means that
they have to isolate if they test
positive
and then the whole bubble has to isolate
and you get all that disruption
to uh to education that we don't want to
see so the
so the aim of it of vaccinating children
is essentially
to protect older people not you're not
worried about children
so i'm so sorry i missed that question
the aim
of uh extending the vaccination down the
age range to children
is more because you want to protect
older people than because you're worried
about spread amongst children well
the spread amongst children does have an
impact on others
and critically we know how much it
disrupts education as well
and then there is this uh the problem of
of long covered in some children who get
who
test positive so there's there's plenty
of good reasons to do this
but we also will want to be very uh
careful and make sure that we listen to
the scientific
advice on exactly what approach we take
are you listening to tony blair this
morning he suggested that um
the we should be able to discriminate uh
in favor of those who are fully
vaccinated businesses should be able to
give
extra freedoms to those who can show
that they are
fully jabbed is that part of your plan
well this is what the certification
review is going to is looking into
and that will report soon the good news
is we now have the technology available
to do this right if you download the nhs
app right now and and you get yourself
registered on it
then you will be able to see your
vaccine status you know if i open my nhs
app
it shows and can prove that i've had in
my case one jab
um and which jab and the date that you
had it and so
we've got the technology in place we
know this is going to be needed because
for international travel some other
countries have said that they're going
to require this sort of proof
and and so we're putting that in place
but in terms of using this domestically
um we haven't gone there yet we have
this certification
review and we'll be publishing the
results of that question
i do like the word yet there secretary
of state
it sounds that you are actually open to
the blair advice
well the um this debate has been going
on for
uh for months and we've been doing the
work inside government
and we'll be coming out with our answers
uh to that
soon when i say yeah the thing is that
we know that this is going to be needed
internationally because some other
countries have said that it will
including uh for instance
uh the eu and so being able you know my
my one of my jobs is to me is to make
sure you
uh and everybody watching has the
ability to prove that you've
had the jabs so that if say the eu bring
this in as they've said they will then
you'll be able to
um to travel when it's safe to do so not
yet sadly but when it's safe to do so
so we we know this is going to be needed
internationally
on the domestic front you know um that's
that's a matter for for michael cove
okay
central state um what you've told me is
the data we're not sure
and so on and so forth um one of the
reasons that we are uncertain is this
indian
variant and i wonder if you would accept
that
frankly you've only got yourself to
blame for this you put pakistan
on the red list at the beginning of
april
uh when the metrics uh were at a certain
point it then took you a further
more than two weeks to put india on
the red list even though its metrics
were worse than pakistan uh this is
your fault isn't it
well the facts in your question were
wrong i've been through this
many times including on this program
with uh a couple of weeks ago
so the positivity of those coming in
from from india was a third what it was
those coming from pakistan and
at the dates that you mentioned we
didn't even
know about the b1617.2
variant and so uh that you have to make
these decisions on the data that you've
got you can't make decisions on the
basis of data that you only find out
afterwards uh because it obviously isn't
available so
i i'm afraid there are some people who
were putting it about
that india was in uh so there are some
people who are putting it about that
india was in a worse state than pakistan
at that moment when we took that
decision
but unfortunately it isn't true that is
not the question i ask i
i'm reading your data here within days
of pakistan reaching 4.6 percent
uh of positivity you had
pakistan on the red list it took you
two weeks from knowing that india
had a positivity rate of 5.1 percent to
put
india on the red list why why
no i i don't recognize those figures
they're your numbers well what i can
tell you what what i can tell you
is that as we saw the case rates rise in
india
and as we saw the uh this new variant
the now
delta variant arriving then we took the
action to put india on the red list and
yeah i'm it's tough action but i'm very
glad that we took it in the same way
that this last week
we saw the the this
potentially dangerous new variant in
portugal nobody's going to contest that
you made the right call tough action all
the rest of it it's just it took you a
long a long time
and longer than it could have done and
nobody's going to complain now but i'm
just saying
looking back now would you accept that
you could
have done this days before uh
the time when you did and remember
during that period it's estimated that
something like 20
000 people arrived from india when
actually we could have had that them on
the red list
well i'm i'm groaning trevor because um
i i
i i absolutely think hindsight is it is
very helpful
and um of course during apparently you
get more information
but you have to take decisions with the
information that you have at the time
and
you know you can't ask anybody uh to
take decisions with information that
doesn't
isn't yet in your hands if
uh even if you'd like to be able to
predict the future
i i'm just reading the information you
had at the time but let's just deal with
something that's happening this week
you want to support the developing world
and you want to use
um their stocks to vaccinate british
children um
are you worried that we're going to in a
way look
like we don't care about the rest of the
world because we're you we're
going to extend vaccination program down
the age range
when actually for example in africa
only 2.5 percent have been vaccinated
and we could be
giving more stocks to african countries
now
i i am i'm uh i i'm going to answer this
question but first i'm going to
i i'm afraid you can't get away with
making a comment on my previous answer
and then just moving on when the comment
was wrong
you have to take information with the
decisions with the information you have
at the time
and the information that you've been
talking about was not
was not available to ministers at the at
that time so
you know that's why we took those
decisions we took the right decisions
based on the information that we
had and of course information came
forward subsequently now
moving on to the other question which
was very which is also very important
my first duty is to protect the uk
population
and that does include trying to minimize
uh transmission
and the way that we're helping the rest
of the world
is primarily with giving away
at no cost the oxford astrazeneca
vaccine this was an agreement we came to
over a year ago
and it means that of the 2 billion doses
delivered around the world
500 million of them are
the oxford astrozenica vaccine seventy
percent of that that the
oxford astrozenica vaccine doses are in
low and middle income countries i'm
incredibly proud of this
and the reason that we've been able to
do that is because we've made it
available
at costs no charge for the intellectual
property from the start
so i'm delighted now there is a global
debate including around the g7 table
about how we can do more to vaccinate
the world but this country
has done more than any other by making
sure that from the start that oxford
vaccine
has been available at cost and that's
why within the kovacs program which is
the program
that is designed to get vaccines to p to
countries that can't afford them
themselves
96 of the doses are our oxford
astrazeneca vaccine
delivered at cost so you know absolutely
let's get this done but
we've been on this for over a year yeah
is this
is this going to be associated with your
big challenge this week
which is over the foreign aid budget
are you going to count the value of
those
uh doses that you send to africa as part
of the foreign aid
budget in order to drive up the
percentage
um no so the doses that are being
made made around the world 20 different
factories around the world
at no cost that doesn't count as aid
you know it doesn't take aid to help the
world what we've done is we've invented
a vaccine that's easy to transport easy
to administer
and we have we made an agreement with
oxford university in astrazeneca over a
year
ago to deliver it at cost so obviously
the money we also put into kovacs counts
as aid
but the really big contribution is is
getting this vaccine out to everyone
as cheaply as we as we possibly can so
it shows that you can help the world
with
far more things than just overseas
development aid and this is probably the
biggest gift this country could give to
the rest of the world
is to make a vaccine to put in the money
into the science and then to make it
available at cost
um i'm going to talk to tom tugan
hartson in a few minutes
uh secretary of state um he
is one of it is estimated 30 or 40
rebels on this foreign aid uh
amen legislation um what can you offer
him
to persuade him uh to fall in line
well i i think that the decisions that
the government's taking around this are
entirely reasonable we face a once in
300 year economic interruption
the cost of that the exchequer has been
hundreds of billions of pounds
so it is reasonable absolutely
reasonable in the circumstances
when we're delivering over 10 billion
pounds of aid as a country
and we're making available this
vaccine at cost and we
have a have such a strong history in
this area it is absolutely reasonable to
take the decision that the government
has
secretary i can't let you go without
giving you the opportunity to reply to
um what has been said about you
by a former senior advisor at number 10
uh dominic tummings told mps last week
that you should have been
fired at least 15 times for lying you
have said since
then that you've always told the truth
there's no middle way here
no room for misunderstanding which one
of you is lying
well i i told the house of commons this
i spoke to responded in the house of
commons
the week before last about these
comments
and i was absolutely categorical about
it
obviously i work incredibly closely with
the prime minister
and i talked to him about about all
things to do with
health and in particularly covert all
the time
i'm completely straight about what we
know what we don't know the challenges
we've got and what we're trying to
achieve
and that's what i said to the house of
commons
and uh and frankly i think we should
leave it there
cummings made it up to be clear
well all i can i i i can't give you an
insight
into that all i can tell you is what i
know to be true
and that is that i've worked you know
every waking hour on this over the past
year and a half
and um i've been absolutely
straightforward in
answering questions including where we
don't know things as we've in our
discussion today
and whether in public or private one of
the challenges of a
of a pandemic is you have to make
decisions based on
uncertainty you have to be able to
communicate that